no I love your talent you know I love
your soul but I also really love your
wine because we do care and you had your
wine man and I was like you've got to
bring your wine so this is your wine yes
this is lve legend vineyard exclusive we
partner with a company called Raymond
vineyards up in Napa Valley and we make
rose' we make Cabernet we make sparkling
Chardonnay years ago with 2013 Cabernet
and a 2014 Chardonnay and we've grown to
all of these and it's doing so well that
that's messing around like it's really
good you know like how people like
celebrities be like yeah the wine I have
this I have that it's like this is
actually good well well Raymond
vineyards is like really highly rated
they make really great wines and so I
was trying to think about you know
getting the best partner and we found
them and started working with them and
we just hit it off and let's have some
yeah it's your wine I'll take some so
wait you said you okay cuz it's lve so
you didn't you didn't call it love for
because it's called what it's legend
legend vineyard exclusive but it's kind
of it love you know like it
now I'm stealing from her - oh I'm okay
I mean it's really good
like I'm so sad y'all aren't drinking
now I know what to bring to give away to
the audience if I'm gonna be like ours I
have a company called get lifted film
company we produce film and television
and one of our shows is our season
finales tomorrow
it's called Sherman's showcase it's on
IFC it's a everybody I didn't seen it
what is it about it's a sketch comedy
show so think like you know laughing
thing and Living Colour
oh my god you know those vibes but it's
all about a music show so it's loosely
based on a fictional music show that's
kind of like Soul Train
so it's musical it's comedy it's really
funny and it's written by these guys
Diallo and Bashir who used to write at
Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon and they
came to us with the idea to do this show
and we were like let's do it and we've
had the season going on IFC for for the
first season it's going so well because
we've used this against me several times
in the voice that you were a teacher and
it works cuz he gets a lot of great
people but you was a music director like
a choir director but I never actually
taught in the schools
I taught at church and I still teach and
I taught like a acapella group at school
that's on college yeah that's hard to
ring a lot of people it is yeah it makes
me a good coach on the voice I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this